l' incendie s'est déclaré dans ce dépôt
situé juste derrière moi de jeu de
spectacles pyrotechniques ont explosé
peu avant 8 heures il devait être livré
ce matin
l'explosion a provoqué de graves
dégradations quatre habitations ont été
impactées et trois voitures ont été
endommagées par la chute de matériaux
la difficulté c'est d'abord le nombre
important d'appels qu'on a eue au xviii
plus de plus de 20 appels en quelques
minutes et puis surtout l'arrivée sur
les lieux déjà un panache de fumée
visible à des kilomètres à la ronde
ce qui ne laissait aucun doute sur
l'ampleur du sinistre et ensuite pour
les équipiers c'était de se protéger
derrière les bâtiments existants pour
pouvoir attaquer le feu et tout en
s'assurant qu'il n'y avait plus de
matières explosives encore impacté dans
le sinistre au total 25 pompiers venant
de villersexel vesoul et lui auront été
déployés ainsi que la gendarmerie
d'héricourt
une enquête a été ouverte et confiée à
la brigade d'héricourt